former presidents Barack Obama and
George W Bush are offering sharp
criticism of the current political
climate neither mentioned President
Trump during separate and unrelated
appearances yesterday but both men
appeared to rebuke him Julianna Goldman
is in Washington with the extraordinary
messages Juliana good morning good
morning it is incredibly rare to see two
former presidents at separate public
speeches on the same day and it's also
an unspoken rule that former presidents
regardless of their party do not
criticize the current officeholder which
makes their comments yesterday so
striking folks don't feel good right now
about what they see at a campaign event
in Virginia last night former President
Barack Obama didn't name names
he didn't have to weed out folks who are
deliberately trying to make folks angry
to demonize people who have different
ideas to get the base all riled up
because it provides a a short-term
tactical advantage earlier in New Jersey
mr. Obama said Americans were
confronting the same politics of
division that date back centuries we
thought we put that to bed looking 50
years back we've seen our discourse
degraded by casual cruelty also
yesterday appearing before a packed room
in New York former President George W
Bush said America has to quote recover
our own identity at times it could seem
like the forces pulling us apart are
stronger than the forces binding us
together mr. Bush warned that the
current discourse was undermining
American democracy our politics seems
more vulnerable to conspiracy theories
and outright fabrication we've seen
nationalism distorted into nativism
people of every race religion ethnicity
can be fully and equally American it
means that bigotry or white supremacy in
any form is blasphemy against the
American creed
a spokesman for President Bush said he's
been discussing the same themes for
decades but as he left the hall
yesterday mr. Bush reportedly was asked
if he thought his message would be heard
in the White House Norah according to
the New York Times he smiled and said I
think it will Julianna thank you so much